In general, when we want to compute the slope of a line, we look at two points.
We can label these points P1 and P2. We use a subscript to indicate which point
it is. Now, these points could have any coordinates. So it'd be really
unspecific or general in mathematical speak. We're just going to say that this
point has some x coordinate and some y coordinate. We'll label the point x sub 1
and y sub 1. The 1 is a subscript and it tells us which point we're on.
Likewise, I could label this point x sub 2, y sub 2. We know slope is the ratio
of the rise divided by the run. So this distance would just be the rise. If I
wanted to find the rise between these two points, I would want to look at the y
values. I would want to know how these y values changed. For example, if this y
value was 5 and this y value was 3, I would just subtract them to figure out the
rise. It'd be 2. We can see that the vertical distance or the rise is just the
difference between the two y values, y2 minus y1. Knowing this information about
the rise, which of the following do you think could represent the run? Is it the
sum of the x coordinates, the difference of the x coordinates or the difference
of the y coordinates?